all right let's go last all right let's
get into this game cooked
dinner so last night the boys cooked
dinner um
cooked might be an overstatement
okay so last week on love island just to
keep you guys in the loop
we had a couple new girls show up one of
them was named mickey
and she stole our bill from us but no
worries because we
dove in right in on aj and gave her a
couple smoochy smooches
and that's where we are now so we've
kissed the go
kissed a lady and we liked it
nice case all right so ella dine on
these nuts
how's this fruit salad i don't know
we're not gonna eat it
this is better than sex um these no
these empanadas are better than sex
no they're not
[Laughter]
uh so then camilla took her out to the
balcony
i wish i had a balcony all right or a
window for that matter
so nobody made dinner for us we had a
microwave cheeseburger
oh no no this is the this is the fake
ian oh that's this host
okay yeah i had a cheeseburger you
stretch out across the bed i've got so
much space i wish i had someone to share
it with
maybe this is just to ourselves um maybe
i should slip into someone else's bed
yeah yeah yes sir
yep yep yep yes i can think of at least
one person looking around you realize
there's only one person in the back room
you get naked and start masturbating
looks like i overslept again nice and
let me sleep
yeah you start this one person here
cordell is using an egg beater
to vibrate her pretty [ __ ]
uh nice to let me sleep maybe they'll
all uh they all got abducted by aliens
why would you ever say that to yourself
maybe they all got abducted by aliens
oh nice nice look at that [ __ ] i like
that
well i guess it's up to me to save
humanity is slowly going insane
step one get out of bed all right we get
out of bed
let's pick let's pick our outfit for the
day i work can we just go
butt ass naked i wish where's the nude
option
where's the tatas out
first of all we don't do nothing free
okay we're about to [ __ ]
we'll we'll re-up on those gems yeah why
don't we just yeah
you know what i like the red that's a
little saucy i'm with it
purchased 10 british quid
you've got a new saucy red bathing suit
for 10 quid
i'm sorry ian i'm really sorry ella dine
on these nuts wow codell that outfit
really brings out your tits
you're everything you're everything is
that your vagina yeah
yeah no your vagina's out you didn't put
your [ __ ] on right
it's eating your bathing suit
we were just talking about dreams i'll
do your favorite topic oh [ __ ] yeah dude
what happened in your dream elodine
nikki oh we went to this
crazy place and you were in the elevator
for some reason and then
ella dying on these nuts nikki and i
both had dirty ones last night oh
they're just literally filthy wait no i
do kind of care
let's see filthy dreams yeah just yeah
we were just
we're just like swimming through a pile
of mud and then we ate dirt for dinner
mine was about some girl called stacy
i don't even know stacy i don't even
know stacy
elytine won't tell us who erz was about
though
um who do i think ella dean had a
sex dream about nikki another islander a
random celebrity
uh i want to stir the pot i say another
islander yeah
do it do it i bet it was something else
like
bill no come on come on [ __ ] no one is
[ __ ] dreaming about bill
yeah literally no one
that guy's an aerospace engineer on the
wrong show
if you did dream about bill be like just
[ __ ] wake me up yeah
no she'd wake up and her [ __ ] would be
coughing yeah
water oh i've had a dream about bill
quick
moisturize my [ __ ]
one of the girls then ooh
not my style babe vibes oh babes
it wasn't anyone in here okay all right
don't keep us in suspense babes what is
this pointless ass conversation
oh we're all friends here no judgment
okay so in the dream i was at a fancy
party ah gave a [ __ ]
i don't care hurry up like don't care
about dreams do not care about dreams at
all
i was cinderella it was very romantic
and then
shut up matt mckinnon who where the [ __ ]
is matt
who's that oh no not that guy
he he face palms dramatically he's this
singer he's well cheesy
when's the next recoupling damn
did you just have a dream about ed
sheeran we're [ __ ] over
it's kind of hilarious to think about
anyone having a sex dream about ed
sheeran what i'm thinking about right
now
it was so hot really
genevive oh i love him he's got that
song your eyes and mind yeah you know
that one
i'm asking do you know that no i'm so
bored by this conversation yeah
let's get to the real [ __ ] yeah let's
skip past
all this i don't even literally then he
took me to the balcony don't care hope
the sex is better than his music
don't care she blushes don't care i
don't remember the details but it was
very good
yeah because it was your dream milk
before bed see
what did i say peanut butter right yeah
no you said milk did i say milk you said
milk yeah
wow that's a science dude wow that's a
science i'm gonna drink a [ __ ] ton of
milk tonight
yeah it's his name a jug of milk
babe what are you doing i'm starting
my sleep with the three gallons
spinning out the sides
dumping on your head
what is it about this game that brings
out the [ __ ]
nine-year-old in me all right
keep going you're like babe
come to the room two jugs of milk and
then you slip smash them and then you
suck off the floor
[Laughter]
is there any food that gives me weird
dreams
um i have weird dreams anyway yeah say
that
yeah i have weird dreams anyway i don't
need food to give me bizarre dreams they
happen anyway
what was the last dream you had oh my
god if this [ __ ] conversation about
dreams
goes any uh sexy sexy yeah got it
i was getting nailed involved more than
one person
whoa there are people i know as well
aj and ellie they were my parents nikki
i was there
oh [ __ ] what
it was my uncle's
what
[Laughter]
that's because i had strawberry milk
before
[Laughter]
remember banana milk what about it
remember drinking it no you never drank
that [ __ ] no
so good no did you guys drink banana
milk
all right so now we've got to tour
around yo let's go let's go to bill and
[ __ ] call him a small dick
yeah yeah let's bully bill yeah
[ __ ] you bully bill bully bill bully
bill bully bill
uh puss face and commit excuse me virgin
and camilla
are in the middle of a heated discussion
when you arrive you plop them down on
the bean bag between them
hi guys hello
nah bruv are you going to the cocktail
all the way all right
the nope the best sauce is mayo i mean
of course bill
yeah i'm gonna agree with him on that
though
[Laughter]
have you even had ahi picante
no but that's my point in it mayo goes
to anything
okay this is literally like love island
you know what it goes the best with
bananas yeah you ever had banana milk
with mayo
uh all right roll past this so we can
just bully this [ __ ] idiot
just like i just like cussing at him
what's my opinion on sources so spicy
all the way
i prefer milder sauce how long have you
been arguing about yeah let's be mean
yeah god [ __ ] you guys
[Music]
he starts beat boxing
[Laughter]
reminds me of a joke okay i can't wait
for this what do you call a noble hot
sauce
what do you think it's gonna be um what
oh sriracha my god
call it out yeah yeah
to be fair i didn't to be fair i didn't
fair play to him
uh pretend i didn't know if you if you
like
okay oh god this is painful
this is the worst chat what is this
give me strength hot sauce doesn't make
a good joke
i can't wait to rub hot sauce on bill's
eyelids in his sleep
yeah seriously what
um you think this is funny yeah
uh play it what should i do play it cool
flirt with bill flirt with camilo
flirt with camilla right in front of
bill yeah make bills
feel like a small dick loser
you lightly stroke camillo's leg with
your foot little flip play
let's go when he looks at you you give
him your best sexy eyes
you lightly kick camilo in the nuts oh
and he goes lightly to you 20 more
you continue to kick camilo's nuts as
bill wishes he was there
he pulls out his phone and says wait
this could be its own video
five more
your muay thai classes pay off what
quick time sequence event and you're
just having a
smash this nuts all right maybe next
time we chat it'll be a different kind
of saucy
cool yeah mint oh [ __ ] tick tocker
you know like mint sauce
damn why are we even hitting on this guy
he sucks more than bill
now now i know why they hang out yeah
seriously we have no game hey dude
what's your favorite sauce by the way
man
uh definitely ahi picante
really man i'm more of a male fan are
you serious
are you serious mayonnaise yeah is way
better than mayo names
you know what i like perrynase from
nando's
i do like that sauce bill raises his
eyebrows and gives you a look oh this is
kind of awkward to build here
yeah oh maybe it will be [ __ ] safe oh
we bout we just bailed
what yeah see around boys later [ __ ]
losers
jesus
later losers holy [ __ ] later
imagine two guys dude and a [ __ ]
hot girl walks up and she's like how
long have you guys been arguing about
this
i'm like seven minutes seven minutes but
he thinks that mayo is the best sauce
and obviously it's salsa papante later
i'm out of here
let's go wait wait wait wait wait before
you go what do you call a regal sauce
sir raja all right
[ __ ]
let's go for it with aj she's working
out dude yeah okay sick
smash it
aj and genevieve are in the gym first of
all you're not in this gym you're just
at it
yeah it's not in anything yeah yeah
genevieve has a serious look on her face
aj is doing a crossbody shoulder
that's the hottest stretch cross body
shoulder stretch
what's going on we were talking about
our arm day routines and it kind of
escalated
what the [ __ ] we're gonna arm wrestle oh
hell yeah oh let's go
put your hands together and let me slide
my pretty [ __ ] on top
that's fun yeah let's that's fun
that sounds like fun [ __ ] do it naked
you're cordell being a creep that sounds
like a lot of fun
dude naked what if we lubed your arms up
what if you foot wrestle
i'm not sure about this just do it
scared
no i just don't want to hurt you oh hell
yeah let's go
genevieve snaps aj's arm in two her
forearm is hanging
over the base of her elbow
who's my money on to win the arm wrestle
um
ref's got to be neutral because we got
to be able to sleep with both of them
yeah yeah yeah
boo what a cop-out i mean i mean aj aj
aj
aj genevieve nods approvingly i mean
jennifer
now i want a good clean wrestle pull
down your pants
slide up with this with this lube oil
and go to work
you can brace against the table but i
want to see
race against me but i want to see feet
firmly planted all right
you raise your arm as the two women lock
hands okay
go they start to strain i'm not seeing
much on here
what should i do could have animated a
little bit of an armrest make some noise
cover your eyes distract them make some
noise
how would you cover your eyes you shout
and whoop like you're watching a cage
fight
but [ __ ] gun
genevieve grits her teeth and tries
genevieve grits her teeth and tries to
concentrate aj bites her lip to keep
from laughing
[ __ ] her up aj get that get it get it
dude
work the elbows aj work the elbow come
on just keep your feet down
use your shoulders if you have to like
[ __ ] relax
sorry north south north south
focus
suddenly genevieve's hand comes crashing
into the table
worse
damn uh now that i think about it i
probably should have bet
on the professional athlete oh is that a
little dance what a little dance no i
was just thinking about
someone just clipping that and booyah
booyah you can use that
oh nice one aj talk about strong biceps
all right aj's ripped i'm so sorry i did
warn you
all right right off to make some
breakfast and put heat back on my arm
damn
she walks off oh let's [ __ ] let's go
let's go
it's time time with aj let's go smash it
smash it
aj flexes around wiggling her wiggling
her fin you want to try oh
wow i read that differently you want to
try to [ __ ] i read that definitely want
to say
you want to [ __ ] aj is challenging an
arm wrestle
uh anything to hold your hand yeah let's
go let's hit it oh
hit it anything to hold your hand
you don't have to arm you don't arm
wrestle me to hold my hand [ __ ] yeah
oh god damn i'll have to remember that
you lock hands aj's skin is warm and her
palms are rougher than you expected oh
you managed to put up a surprisingly
good fight but in the end
aj's boundless energy is too much for
you you giggle and laugh as you roll
onto the grass and both your tops
shoot off
your nipples continue to rub against
each other arm wrestle in the grass
all of a sudden the bear approaches with
the pies
bad bear you stole those pies
he pies them both
it's so hot that was fun let's do it
again sometime
all right aj stands up and stretches
damn she's doing that cross
cross shoulder stretch again shit's so
hot shit's so [ __ ] hot i'm gonna have
to shower before i go to breakfast
okay let me join you she squeezes her
tits past you and you
what i got to stop this dude against
each other for a moment
i was joking but now it's for real
i'm sorry um aj's pressed up against me
we still haven't moved i should have
moved
i'm enjoying it i'm enjoying it hit it
aj blush is more oh it's [ __ ] on
me
you're making me randy baby
she jogs off towards the villa her big
jug's bouncing in the air
she jogs off backwards
[Laughter]
somehow she jogs off
somehow she knows everybody
so emoji knows every step going
backwards while she shimmies
she perfectly goes back up every step
while running backwards
she runs off backwards and pours a jug
of milk over herself
and then goes to sleep all right what's
going on in the pool
[Laughter]
hey i'm harry i'm on set for the day
do you need your battery pack replaced
the sound guy says i can replace
batteries if i feel like
who am i interested in aj
[Laughter]
you yeah right you yeah who are you
interested in but who are you interested
in by the way who do you have a crush on
not you okay
no worries
my dad said i could be on set for the
day
my dad said i don't have to wear a shirt
if i'm near the pool
my dad said i could go swimming with you
guys so you can't tell me to get out of
the pool if i'm in the pool
i brought my ripstick you want to see it
yeah uh my dad's boat we have a sea-doo
that'll let you go underwater
he wouldn't let me bring it though our
bill is nicer than this
[Music]
all right he's talking to her but we
don't care uh
harry water splashes
oh mickey's face pops up from the edge
of the pool what's up with the
mischievous grin on her face
okay lona is that lona or iona
is bobbing behind her what i don't know
she's bobbing behind her
just like hey
should i join them in the pool jump in
and splash harry yes
yeah that kid
um you make a mighty splash because your
big old dumper hits the water
and it splashes hairy with butt with
butt water
hey hey what the heck i'm allergic to
water
you're gonna get your battery pack wet
[Laughter]
now i have to go replace it
it's okay i'm gonna go find a towel to
dry off cool dude later
i feel bad could be fine yeah
damn what is what's going on over here
who the [ __ ] is iona
what a crazy look does she have
pupils i don't know i don't think so
their eyes are all white from here
what's a fan dan fandon a silk shirt
wearing skunner
what's a skunner it's like it sounds
like an
ultimate new term sexy [ __ ] stunner
oh skunner the lad who'd take carlo
montano to dinner right before she was
due to marry his evil twin brother this
is so british i don't know what the [ __ ]
this is at all
all right mickey and iona have an
extremely british conversation yeah
um i hope it didn't replace something
important you have to watch
ammo and el rancho both of you
it's this amazing tele novella okay
let's talk about tv
they're just itv plugging their other
shows in it
oh you've absolutely got to watch this
telenovela called amoranel rancho
i've seen every episode
yeah yeah smash that oh my gosh
not just a quiz about that show wait no
no no no
both you lasses are lovely as you are
okay cool person [ __ ] in the pool you
know
you splash about with mickey and iona
for a bit competing to see who can make
the biggest wave with their arms
all right forget telling other
characters i want to be um
let's be weird let's be an octopus yeah
you swim after making iron waving your
arms like a octopus
and try to get away from you but you
managed to catch them it turns into an
impromptu game of octopus
tag what the [ __ ] is that what is going
on when you stick your toe in someone's
mouth yeah yeah you're it you're right
i'm gonna go hunt down some brekkie aj's
aj's nipples
three of you get out of the pool mickey
and iona head off to the villa
someone's been crafting hard you've
chatted to everyone time to see what
happens next oh
we did it we chatted to everyone okay
find genevieve in the kitchen
smash through this the air sizzles with
the sound and scent
hey you know i'll try to make some
breakfast
it is literally just blast through this
amazing i mean let's try to get to the
end of the day that's what i mean blast
through this it's just [ __ ]
we don't care all right so we'll find
out what happens next week
yes and also to to whoever they're
getting shot or in short uh
[ __ ] hour five at least
[ __ ] [ __ ] you yeah [ __ ] you
sit here on a podcast for 10 days
straight if i so please you
[ __ ] ass oh sorry i'll let it go